alejandro tiene nueve canicas y anna
tiene cinco canicas cuántas canicas más
tiene alejandro de las que tiene a na
pausa en el vídeo e intenten resolver el
problema por su cuenta
ahora vamos a resolverlo paso a paso
vamos a dibujar las nueve canicas de
'alejandro' aquí está una dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho y nueve
y ahora dibujemos las canicas de 'la una
dos tres cuatro y cinco cuantas canicas
más tiene alejando de las que tiene and
pues podemos verlo en el dibujo hasta
este punto coincide en el número de
canicas de alejandro con las de amd y
vemos que alejandro tiene además una dos
tres cuatro canicas
veamos ahora otra forma de resolver esto
alejandro tiene nueve canicas y si le
restamos el número de canicas que tiene
al menos cinco pues tendremos las
canicas de más que tiene alejandro que
es igual a cuatro
resolvamos otro problema nos envió dos
cartas por correo la carta más pesada
usó ocho timbres y la más ligera usó
cinco timbres menos cuántos timbres
postales usó la carta más ligera pausa
en el vídeo y tratan de resolverlo por
su cuenta siempre es útil comprender lo
que nos están diciendo y anotar la
información que nos dan ocho timbres
para la carta más pesada y la carta
ligera uso cinco timbres menos y nos
preguntan cuántos timbres se usaron en
la carta más ligera
sabemos que usó cinco menos que la más
pesada le restamos cinco lo cual nos va
a dar igual a tres
por lo que la carta más ligera tendrá
tres timbres solamente otra forma de
resolver esto es dibujar los ocho
timbres de la carta más pesada
aquí los dibujamos uno
ok y ahora tachamos los cinco timbres -
quitamos uno quitamos dos tres cuatro
cinco y nos vamos a quedar con estos
tres timbres que tiene la carta más
ligera